actually I got a good question for you
guys what's the one time you click bait
it that you're like even you look at
that video you like oh man I'm
disappointed to myself for going for
click baiting that hard do you have that
have you ever clicked oh you prefer yeah
yeah probably my most successful video
12 things not to do in Japan that is
still to this day on my recommended even
though I've watched it already I think
that video the reason why I did so well
is not because the clickbait boy you
know when you released it yeah I really
stick by [ __ ] I think I released it one
week before Logan Poole did oh hey oh my
god don't be like a poll number 10
that's like you know 20% of them Ryan
well because literally I think it was
like 7 out of the 12 things you said
Paul he didn't even have to make a
statement like like a different
statement like that video just spoke for
itself
yeah good old Logan poll we got me a
viral here great great man like it's
like it just comes down to like what
even is clickbait any more fryer because
like I think as long as you deliver on
the title that is the main thing like
the video I talked about earlier what
what was it what I the one that you did
that I did watch man like you know what
about your hand what I'll never
understand about Japan that sounds quite
clear a in the you know this thumbnails
be going it was some beer looking really
shocked it's a bit vague but as long as
the subject is all the content delivers
on the title I think it's okay to have a
provocative clickbait stout tight I mean
yeah it's a good argument because like
clickbait what is clickbait indian is
there's there's like different levels in
my eyes you know what I mean though if
you like it happened again and it's you
going I'm so sorry and it was him
it's literally is flight getting yeah I
think it was cold like no it was cold
like we're so angry and then in brackets
I'm sorry oh yeah just like my flight
got canceled and all [ __ ] like
Allegiant airlines I watched that video
yeah that flight for no [ __ ] reason
and we missed our convention to Finland
I watched that video I was like 1.2
million views this is a video but it's
20 title no doubt yeah you know there's
always the content delivers and gives
viewers something I took a game yeah
total I mean I knew what I was doing
when I titled it away